so transfer learning is when you  transfer your knowledge from one domain  to a new totally new domain and I think  that is the key to actually general  intelligence and that's the thing that  we as humans do amazingly well for  example I played so many board games now  when if someone was to teach me a new  board game I wouldn't be coming to that  fresh anymore I would know you know  straight away I could apply all these  different heuristics to that I've  learned from other games to this new one  even if I've never seen that before  and currently no machines can do that  and I think the key to doing transfer  learning is going to be conceptual  knowledge so abstract knowledge so these  so the acquisition of conceptual  knowledge that is abstracted away from  the perceptual details of where you  learnt it from so then you can go look  okay I'll apply it to this new domain so  I think that's actually one of the the  big challenges to be tackled towards  general AI